uh-huh is this are you sure I don't know
am i hitting the target walk about to
Glamour with me joshing haste and say
which one by the start of widows Michele
what I loved about this is you kind of
like the more badass version of
Destiny's Child but what did you learn
about badassery from your fellow
actresses would you say Oh God viola my
God would have forced her I mean to have
somebody laughing in your face and then
five minutes later she's like you know
just don't scream just like this force
to be reckoned with
it was just really really inspiring cuz
I mean I work on mostly commercial films
and rarely get an opportunity to really
play with the tool you know yeah and so
this was this was refreshing
I liked that play with the tool this is
a baby this is gonna ask what should you
learn about yourself as an actor how to
destroy the ego that's my biggest lesson
um cuz you know to play somebody like
linda's it was rough for me because you
know first off I had like why would I
play a woman who puts herself in the
situation to begin with we can dodge
that bullet honey I know but it's it's
it's that whole thing of like women who
love unconditionally and who would do
anything for their children and further
for their husbands and I needed to dive
into what it is like for a woman who
does that and loves unconditionally
because it's a very powerful thing I
think it's more soft power is way I
think more powerful than than hard power
yeah and so for me it was just it was a
journey to drive it let me tell you it
ain't easy also what I loved about is
these women are feminine but they also
not define themselves by the masculine
tooth them of the man and they're going
out there and they're reclaiming
themselves which I thought was just such
an incredible story was that kind of a
new wave of the script when you read it
you were like this is a very new script
for me like where's the part where I get
to like kill everybody with
my weapon or when do I get to make
something explode yeah I mean know is
all internal explosions and that's the
beauty of it you know now you're working
now you're working with with with a guy
who understands the subtleties of being
human and it loves to explore those most
uncomfortable moments where birth
happens and and I realize you know
facing your fears that's that's the one
place where I found myself in my 40
little years of living that I grow if
you're scared of it
run towards it because that's where
emergence is gonna happen you know
oh and boy does that happen I feel like
such an amazing thing for young girls
and young guys as well to go watch
obviously within the certificate because
it's a fully representative film as well
what would the younger you say watching
this do you think the younger me would
have it totally been all about Daniel
cuz the younger me was very violent
yeah and just understands an animal like
it the character he plays I mean that
kids a beast oh and like that and and
growing up in in inner city that's
that's kind of like what you respect you
respect a beast warrior and that's what
that world is so the younger me would
totally be like Daniel wasa I loved it
you owned a prom shop oh yeah I loved
the Tiaras of the dresses right that's
the ethnicity thing that's the whole
Dominican culture yeah they are really
all about that quinceanera it's kind of
like the Mexicans when way different a
lot more cakier yeah a lot more Prommy
if you know what I mean yeah a hundred
yeah you I'd not shopkeeper roles so
well babe yeah give me the best I love
Iceland they come in like I feel like
this needs a little bit more meringue
how did you cope the physicality of this
role because it's free it's quite
physical but then also it's quite gentle
at the same time I had to tone down my
Michelle
Regas drop the ego and like become mom
and so like it was more about like not
looking like I know what I'm doing as
opposed to knowing what I'm doing it's
like do this done your lat I know how to
do this is this how you should I don't
know am i hitting the target
[Music]